in other news this morning the united
states is ready to send more military
aid to ukraine senior administration
officials tell cbs news the white house
plans to announce this week it is
providing an advanced surface-to-air
missile defense system yesterday for the
first time in three weeks ukraine's
capital was struck by russian missiles
raymie asensio is there
a rare barrage of russian missiles flew
over keeve on sunday
and upon impact plumes of smoke rose
from a kindergarten and residential
building six people were injured
including this seven-year-old girl and
her russian mother her father did not
survive
that missile hit the roof of their
apartment complex but it's actually not
the first time that it's been hit the
last time was about two months ago now
one possibility is that russian forces
are targeting a soviet era arms factory
that's literally this one across the
street
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
said some missiles had been shot down
but called for more modern defenses from
the international community that has
started to arrive these destroyed
military trucks are believed to be the
first russian targets hit by u.s
supplied guided rocket systems known as
highmars that arrived in ukraine just
days ago
too late to save the eastern city of
severo donetsk that city fell on
saturday as ukrainian troops were
ordered to pull out
russia is cementing its control over the
whole donbass region a territorial and
morale hit to ukraine in this war now
starting its fifth month for cbs
morning's raymie in ascencio keeve